oh my God uh oh get off the dance for
you crazy kids
oh that's how we come out
whoa oh come on oh
oh
my kisses later
oh oh my God he's like King's guy oh boy
he said girl come on get out of this get
out of this mess sir Kristen Cole is
down bad every man in this show was down
every single man in this show every man
in this show including renera is down
back uh the only person that's not
thirsty Allison
okay she's had enough yeah Allison's
like I don't know I'm done I hate this
family I hate my kids I hate everything
you guys welcome back to New Rockstars
it's wedding season on the house of the
Dragon I honestly was able to be like if
this is another red wedding I mean my
mind close enough close enough and it
wouldn't be a Noble West real westerosey
wedding without some Bloodshed of course
it's a dangerous game being a spouse on
this series
and just don't get married don't get
married easy easy just don't get married
you guys because someone's gonna get
murdered uh this is a big question
presents talking dragons our weekly
fantasy after show where we talk about
dragons everything we talk about Game of
Thrones we talk about the rings of power
we talk about everything for you I'm
Jessica Clemens here with me today is
Brandon Barry oh hello Jessica oh what a
fun what a fun episode the show is
getting so much fun it's good it's so
fun and this looks like you know if you
saw the what's coming up next episode
it's our last episode with our young our
young crew it's bittersweet it made me a
little sad when I saw them all grown up
I was like oh no yeah as like as actors
I was like I love them as actors they're
great and then I was just sad to be like
we're not gonna see them young again
we're gonna see now a very decrepit the
series oh my look at that I can't
believe he survives another 10 years the
guy I thought five times this episode he
was gonna die and that that's the only
thing from The Flash or the future the
next episode teacher that we got that I
was like he's still alive I was like
he's still alive and that poor man like
that wig and bald cap they put on
again rap okay well we gotta get into it
let's dive into episode five we light
the way the house saying of Hightower uh
so we start off with Damon returning to
his uh wife lady Ria Royce of the veil
only to knock her off her horse kind of
uh scare the horse a little bit
paralyzing her because I was creepy him
stepping on her arm like that and then
looked like he was gonna walk away but
ultimately caving in her skull with the
rock we don't see it happen uh but
that's what happens in the book in the
book it says she fell off her horse and
crushed her skull with a rock or
something like that it looks like he was
gonna do that just that uh lady Raya we
hardly knew you nice to meet you sorry
to see you go sorry to see you go and
then that was the worst part she she
talked so much [ __ ] I know right I
didn't say a word he doesn't say it one
word she talks so much smack and then he
said oh okay you know brings up his
impotence which uh does not go well when
you bring that up with him uh meanwhile
King faceres uh and his new hand Lionel
strong raynera and the whole royal gang
are heading to high tide in driftmark to
meet with the valerians Corliss and
viserys have an icy meeting I would say
you know Corliss makes him walk all the
way into the castle this guy who's ready
to drop dead at any moment doesn't have
a chair wait before it makes him walk
all the way back there he's been Lionel
strongest like yo you don't treat your
king like this and viserys is just so
sick and like seasick and barf he's just
like I don't care I want to get this
over with he doesn't he doesn't waste a
moment you know they're the ones that
tell him about lady Raya dying in a
hunting accident and viserys is pretty
much like yeah a hunting accident
whatever sure next I don't care moving
on uh so he's really there to lay out
the wedding proposal he wants to marry
raniera to their son lane or Valerian
but Corliss and rainis want to know the
succession roles and if the children
will take the Valerian name uh because
you know of course is like I'd love to
have a Valerian as king that would be
great uh and and viserys destroys them
they'll take the Valerian name except
for whoever gets to be king or queen
Queen they will be the name Targaryen
and the targaryens rule will rule for
the next 100 years
and all of his energy to say that last
sentence that was like a hundred years
and he was like Yeah someone give me
some get the maesters uh and of course
reynisa is like very much concerned that
uh with their son marrying rhaenyra like
she's she's brought up before they're
not gonna allow a queen to take the
throne uh she's worried about the safety
of her son uh rhaenyra and Lena are they
chat on the beach and decide to have an
open marriage uh because it's clear
Rainier still wants to have her me time
with sir Kristen Cole and Lena has a
little love of his own name Joffrey the
Knight of kisses the native what a cute
name uh you know I loved him I mean
technically they both like Goose yeah
but they you know it's clear she's she's
known him for a long time they're
cousins she probably knew of his sexual
proclivities was like Hey I'm fine with
it I don't care we got one job to do we
gotta make a couple babies uh but other
than that you do you I do mine will be
cool which seems like a good idea at the
start it's a it's a good proposal you
know know just kind of get it out in the
open and be like we're doing this to
keep our houses strong to keep the realm
together this is the marriage of power
and kind of convenience
we can't both be happy until you guys
start being bitter against each other
yeah right um Meanwhile my girl Allison
has remained at King's Landing she says
bye to her father Otto in a very sense
to me it was really heartbreaking but
not before he warns her that if renera
takes the throne she'll be at her mercy
and have to hope that renera doesn't
have her and aegon killed he they're
stirring the pot yeah they're stirring
the pot even on his way out in the way
that scene was framed right it's like
he's breathing fire like he's telling
her the truth yeah and like this is as
messed up as he is and as messed up as
his relationship is with his daughter he
does care for her here and he's like
he's basically saying I'm scared I'm
worried about you I'm worried about my
grandson like you need to take this very
seriously I'm not going to be here to
protect you anymore like you need to
make sure because yeah if Rainier wants
to take the throne and there's going to
be people saying like hey there's an air
named aegon out there it would be in her
best interest to be like why don't I
kill that why don't I kill him
my brother my brother because that's her
brother her brother yes so I don't think
she would actually fully Go full well
she probably would but it's more so that
like Otto is being very paranoid yeah
and rightfully so oh he just got let go
from his position and I do think he does
love Allison in a horrible way of
showing it but he does care about her
and he cares about his lineage and his
family yeah so he's like our Hightower
name is not going to be besmirched you
better hold on keep that power that I've
worked so hard he is trying so he's
forcing poor owls to do everything while
his son gets knocked off a [ __ ] horse
jousting not doing anything not pulling
his freaking ways yeah where is he at
where's he where's his children probably
back in Old Town living it up living at
Arthur is pretty rich they're like the
richest people well right now the
valerians are very very wealthy they're
probably like the richest people people
yeah the Lannisters are certainly coming
up they're coming out uh and yeah the
high Towers have a lot of old money Old
Town old money money but uh they've lost
a lot of power overly that you know Old
Town used to be the seat of power in in
Westeros before aegon kind of yeah okay
switched it over to King's Landing there
you go we'll see I can't I love these
jumps but I'm also sad to see these
people go I know so Allison has a chat
with Lara strong near the Weeping
weirwood uh where would tree where she
learns about the moon TV series had
prepared for renera people keep getting
into their business she uh has she been
lied to by her husband and her supposed
best friend
you don't know half the story and it's
pissing me off and I love it it's very
it's very farcical very like upstairs
down this is like people know things and
they think they know things but they
actually know other things it's so it's
not even like Petty but this is Game of
Thrones yeah this is literally Game of
Thrones and I love that pettiness of
like well yeah I heard and also he says
that line where it's like sorry about
your dad and it was like yeah but your
dad took his seat so are you really
sorry I'm sorry well it's interesting
how did Laris find out about this is
this something that Lionel strong told
his son to tell the queen like who who
is feeding this information to who yeah
I love it I love the sneakiness
um on the boat back to King's Landing
sir Christian Kroll shoots his shot with
Monera in a very stupid way with the old
let's run away to Asos and get married
idea but renera just can't throw away
her duty to the crown I am the crown she
tells her I mean it's you know it's a
good try my guy you know give up and
save them and run away it's the dumbest
thing it is the dumbest thing and he
even he even says himself in the last
episode of how like important she is and
what he is and how he is like now
forever like in trouble yeah because of
what he did he says it on the boat yeah
so it's like so you're gonna steal her
the one that everyone knows he wants to
run that's what he know he doesn't know
remember he's not from like a very
high-powered family he's not he's not a
man with like a powerful name he's
building this all up uh and he's not
used to All This and like yeah his
instinct is probably to like run away
and go back to a world he knows right a
poorer and bring a Targaryen with him
like No One's Gonna recognize her yeah
that's a good idea but also with me
saying sir Chris and Cole's stupid for
what he said I still love his character
I love his character because let's go on
she does propose that her and Sir
Christian keep their Arrangement going
but his response is so you want me to be
your [ __ ] it's clear they are on
different pages yeah I love that line
he's like this you know he's like I've
already like tarnished my epic name and
that's all I have he's like I harvest my
white cloak my favorite uh Trope and
shows like this this has happened in the
great too is just like the the lower
person a commoner or whatever falling in
love with the princess or queen and
being like I love you and then being
like well I gotta stick to my duties and
it's just like you can't slap me out I
love you it doesn't work like that and
I'm like oh I love it yeah yeah well and
she she knows you know her father has
told her about the Song of Ice and Fire
yeah she knows about that and she knows
her responsibility there yeah it's weird
because like I was rooting for rhaenyra
at first and now as we go within the
season I'm less and less inclined too
okay okay but we'll keep going well back
at King's Landing Allison questions sir
Kristen Cole in a real farcical nature
where she's like trying to find out
about Damon and rhemara but winds up
finding out that sir Kristen and Rainier
are the ones who did the coupling on
that fateful night a few weeks back he
begs for death as punishment uh because
the other punishment is gelding which
sounds uh terrible he doesn't want to be
gilded of course who would want to uh uh
but she instead she finds out it just
dismisses him kind of leaving him deep
in his feelings so now he's walking
around with this hanging over his head
he knows the queen knows about what is
happening and he should be put to death
immediately or should be gilded
immediately instead she's just like like
no go about your business he's gonna be
team Hightower and Allison is gonna sit
there and be like I got your man he's
fighting for me now oh yeah and also
Allison you balls in your court honey
play chess play I mean she's doing a
great job like now he's parano he
doesn't know what's gonna happen just to
walk around and now he doesn't know who
she's gonna tell right wow she's great
good episode for her uh the serest ain't
getting any younger or any healthier uh
and he's worried about his own legacy a
lot of people worried about their
legacies you know he's he's talking to
Lionel strong he's like what are the
songs they're gonna sing about me not
great my guy uh and Lionel's pretty much
like hey you've done an okay job you've
kept the peace there's nothing to be
ashamed of but it's clear that he's
worried about what his legacy is going
to be is he making the right decision
yeah he's a bad King uh he's not a great
king he's not a great king and then he
even notices that he says that he's like
I didn't conquer anything yeah I didn't
do anything and it's like yeah you
didn't Strong's like that's good that's
very submissive very good yeah but it's
wedding time and all the bannermen of
the land are here they're all sailing in
coming into town we see some a couple of
dragons flying in see smoke and I I
assume uh raines's dragon flying in here
uh oh and guess who else is here for the
party that's right surprise our boy
Damon is here too who banished him who
he doesn't care this is a family wedding
of course he's gonna show up viserys
didn't expect to see him I love Valley
has to be like uh at a chair and bring
him a glass of wine or something like
that gets a seat at the end of the table
uh everyone's kind of surprised to see
him uh and also that's when Allison
finally arrives to the welcome banquet a
little fashionably late looking very
fashionable in her green dress of course
during The King's Speech interrupting
him he kind of loses his place I thought
he was gonna drop dead right there when
he was like uh where was I
um but she's in that green dress
signaling that she's here to support her
own family the high Towers we get some
lovely Exposition uh uh where the strong
Brothers explain uh how important green
is to the Hightower hours but it's it's
her family first too that rises up to
like clap for her and applaud her like
she's she's pissed off she's mad at her
husband she's mad at her friend slash
stepdaughter she calls her stepdaughter
to her face uh which is pretty icy uh
and it's clear that she's looking out
for her best interest now she's seen how
dangerous it can be up there and she's
mad about what she's found out from Sir
Christian girl she's been lied to when
you're a swore on her dead mother that
she didn't sleep with Damon she didn't
she didn't sleep with Damon she didn't
sleep with Damon she technically never
lied and that's where I think Allison's
like judgment and whole Fury is
misguided where she's just like I'm
tired of being betrayed to and lied to
but I'm like elephant
you can be mad at the king all you want
but renera doesn't have anything to do
with any of your your dad said that she
had sex with your her uncle and it
wasn't true and it wasn't true just
because she had sex someone else doesn't
make it a problem Jesus as the
festivities began and everyone Dragon
dances and gets on the floor and shouts
hey hey they never say oh he's like I
don't have hoes I kept saying is that it
and I was like okay uh sir Gerald Royce
of runestone accuses Damon of killing
his cousin lady Rhea uh and Damon
basically says yeah I did do it uh and
also I'm gonna inherit your house so you
better be nice this guy I mean he had
kind of half a plan he had half a plant
I don't know what he thought was going
to happen here like you're in the
targaryen's house of power uh that you
know they Ruled the Land you think
you're just going to show up and be like
I accuse you sir and everyone's gonna be
like oh damn it yeah everyone knows
everyone knows my guy it was it was I
mean Kudos on the like respect and
courage I mean respect and courage you
stood your ground and said hey in front
of the king in front of the queen in
front of everybody at this wedding I'm
gonna accuse him
he said okay sit back down yes
go eat your pheasant and shut up
it was a wild it was wild stuff okay and
as the dancing the side glances the
lobster eating and the uncle needs
flirting on the Dance Floor intensifies
he what is wrong with him what's wrong
with her I started getting so close I
was like [ __ ] he's grabbing her face
yeah I was like oh I got so mad my mic
pack came off I was so upset
um okay sir Kristen Cole snaps and beats
Joffrey to death
you guys this scene is horrible that and
then they didn't need to show us that
close-up of literally I think they need
to show you because it's not like even
if sir Crystal Cole is like the guy
pulled a knife right uh which he did
after he was on the ground but if circus
or goal is gonna be like oh I was just
protecting the queen or something like
that right you could stop him you could
hold him down you could punch him a
couple times you can't caught like cave
in his face that's true and it shows how
mad actually looks like you're supposed
to be the best of the best every guard
came run in people start moving away no
one stopped him no one held him back he
got up at the end walked away yeah it
was still I was like
No One's Gonna Stop him no no one can
but maybe that's also what they do back
in the day they're just like yeah we'll
beat someone to death during our dinner
yeah yeah you don't want to catch it you
don't want to catch a stray dagger or
something like that you gotta let it die
down Leonard got punched directly
directly in the eye
um he okay so after the entire fight
happens after Joffrey is dead uh sir
Chris and Cole goes to kill himself like
with a little dagger in God's wood near
the Wayward tree uh where were Drew I
keep pronouncing it wrong but you know
the crying too yeah but lady Allison
stops him just before he plunges the
dagger which is why I think that gotta
be a team oh yeah gotta be a team oh
yeah and they're gonna mess up they're
gonna ruin the targaryens and I'm okay
with it so Rainer and laner marry
quickly literally so speed fast he still
has the lights crying he's crying do
people people know right that maybe
people don't know that that was who he
was with I don't know I mean I'm sure
people assumed they're like I like that
the family was like we're aware of our
son sexuality I think Rainier is aware
of his sexuality
um but I'm like did anyone know because
he cried and crawled to that dead body
yeah and I would have been like why is
he crying so hard
like he could be like oh that was my
guard that was like my favorite guard
you know I guess I guess I'd have been
like boy get up oh okay either right
they get they quickly get married very
very very quickly no guests just the
family likes five people uh with the
small frazzle Gathering of a few
attendees present in this bloodstained
Throne Room accepting joins House
Targaryen in the house of valerian and
as the commitment is sealed viserys
faint he faints he falls and it's like
his crown rolls off his but as we know
from the little uh the little clip for
the next episode he is very much alive
he's still alive I thought well maybe he
finally died I don't know I was really
happy with that scene I was like oh if
he dies here that's a pretty cool ending
yeah but then I saw the next clip and
he's just like like he's like I did it I
got her married my final Act uh yeah but
now he's still alive it makes me wonder
when when Allison comes to Sir Crystal
Cole in the garden and is like stops him
right do you do you think that happened
before that little wedding or after that
little wedding before before I think it
was like right after the
right after that walks directly he
walked out went directly to the tree and
was like I'm gonna kill myself I think
the craziest part is if they're gonna
team up I understand hating the
targaryens but he doesn't hate them he
loves her like that's the problem where
does the love and hate cross lines he
feels betrayed now uh we'll get into all
of it but first uh we want to remind you
to head on over to new
rockstarsmerch.com where you can find
our house of the Dragon inspired latest
Obsession shirt action ruin there it is
baby uh there's tons of other merch on
you can find on the site including some
rings of power merch as well but this is
our latest Obsession for House of the
Dragon get it while you can and when you
purchase a latest Obsession shirt you
also unlock the ability to get a custom
shout out that'll will appear right here
on talking dragons uh so check out new
rockstarsmarts.com it's a great way to
support the channel and we certainly
appreciate it uh so like we were saying
okay things were getting pretty crazy on
that dance floor out there people were
having a good time they were vibing that
little throw dance is fun you just get
to toss people
when they were everyone was kind of out
there just doing a little dance and they
like would toss the woman it was like I
think I saw her get tossed a little bit
there was a little bit of tossing going
on I also like their little like
flying my favorite team my favorite one
was when they go and they step away I
was like did they cry my wife would ever
argue about this do they practice that
like yeah when did they practice you
have to it's probably just like earlier
rehearsals it's like choreography no
it's definitely it was like everyone
know how to do that dance is that the
Macarena no I don't I don't know uh but
that was wild I love to see all the
dancing you know you do a little Dragon
Dance it gets everybody off their feet
everyone that's how you get it this is
the new Cupid Shuffle and then and then
you do a shout and that's what hey was
that was that is uh House of the Dragon
version of shout hey hey a little bit
softer now uh so there was a lot going
on in that whole sequence right I loved
it like everyone's looking at each other
so many side glances people seeing what
everyone else is doing people clocking
each other we even like tie in uh lay in
a Valerian and Damien talking we have
never seen them interact and that that
gave us so much context and so much like
oh I see what's gonna happen next right
so fascinating because I thought they
were teasing that she was gonna marry
someone from braavos
in the previous episode and I kind of
set up you know viserys wanting to marry
Ray yeah uh Ray Meera and Lenore so I
guess that wedding never happened I
wonder if it was even gonna happen or if
that was just Corliss Cruise Line
to make something happen I'm more uh I
feel so bad for this girl lady uh Elena
because she's just or the young lady
Elena she's so sweet and I was like
so there's a lot going on that whole
sequence but let's talk about the big
question okay you know what what lit the
fuse that set off the coal bomb okay our
big question is how did this brawl at
the wedding Feast start okay what really
started the bra I think it was because
uh Joffrey was like he was taking this
as like I don't know if he actually
loved uh Lenor I think it was more so
like he was like oh we have dirt on them
they have dirt on us this is strategic
and he's like this isn't and Christian
Cole's like this isn't strategic for me
I'm actually in love with this woman and
you are ruining that like you and your
man are ruining that for me do not hang
this over my head right now him being
like Oh you're tasty morsel of a girl
and it's like she's not a tasty anymore
so that's the love of my life and and uh
Joffrey the night of kisses he does say
uh uh to Sir Kristen Cole he's kind of
like you know we have our secrets and
the best way keep our people safe is to
keep these secrets safe right and and if
you look at it from Sir Kristen Cole's
perspective if this guy knows about him
and Ray Rayner and he's saying like we
got to keep our people safe and the best
way to keep them Secret Safe well I
could kill this guy that's one that's
one secret no that's very off the board
you know what I mean so it's kind of
like he sealed his own fate a little bit
by pushing him now Grizzly goes in a bad
spot yeah at this at this Feast he's
he's been freaking out ever since the
day him and rainy are coupled if you
will uh he's he's kind of been on edge
right he shot his last shot he was like
let's run away and she's like absolutely
not he's like
I'm screwed I'm stuck here I can't leave
they're gonna cut off my balls or
they're going to kill me and now Allison
knows and that was a self goal that was
our own goal that was a mess up you
you'd never give more Let Her Say the
names before you admission it was like I
wasn't gonna say that she was like not
gonna say that but thank you so much sir
I'll put that in my pocket he's told her
and she just let him go so now he's like
who else knows and while he's at this
party Joffrey walks up to him and it's
like hey I know and it's like did
Allison tell this guy did rhemara tell
this guy or could this guy just see it
on him uh and what he's telling him and
he kind of brushes by him when he walks
away we get another shot of the sword so
many shots of uh sir Kristen Cole's
sword like when he's talking to Allison
he lays it down and we see a shot of it
uh which is for sure what I thought he
was going to go through with stabbing
himself yeah
um I think he just pushed his button so
far and he's like so on the brink that
he's like I've gotta do something and he
wants to die at this point he asked for
death he's like maybe if I I kill this
guy they'll kill me I don't know they'll
let him walk out and they said uh let
him let him walk it off let him walk it
off
um yeah so Kristin Cole's just upset and
as we saw from the jousting tournament
people during this time haven't gone to
war haven't taken their anger out on
doing anything so that anger is so
easily stubbing your toe means you're
gonna murder a child in this time so I
think him just like literally being
pushed off the edge set him off and he
went off but I also I'm like well I mean
keep in mind how mad he gets when he's
triggered right if he's that hot-headed
like he's gonna kill another person well
and this all goes back to rhaenyra
picking this guy to be on the kingsguard
yes he's he was the only guy who had
seen battle uh which seemed like a smart
choice at the time but maybe that wasn't
a good idea yes good does he have like
PTSD from his time out there you know is
he like playing a nice guy but he's
really like he's always been this kind
of rough hot tempered man he's
pretending to be like a good little
Knight and like I could be on the King's
Guard if I just dreamed hard enough uh
but deep down he's like a problem and
like he's easily pushed to anger he
doesn't have control he doesn't know how
to play these games with these rich uh
people of of royalty and of stature he's
a guy who doesn't have that he only has
his effing name as he told right now I
only have my effing name and I'm like
well he wasn't ready to play this game
yeah he wasn't he wasn't built for it
that's on him it's a little tough love
him to death but that's on him that's up
to my guy he dug his own hole a lot this
episode to be fair twice at least do you
think it's possible someone
else set this off because we don't see
it begin and it's really hard to see
who's in the fracchus when it's all
going down like is it possible that
Damon saw what was going on because
again a lot of side glancing in this
episode did Damon notice what was going
on or knew about Sir Christian Cole
could he have gone over to him when he
was out there dancing and being like hey
you know [ __ ] smack I think it's
Joffrey I think it's just Joffrey and I
can't wait for it to be explored in the
next episode of them being like we
should talk about it
yeah remember what that guy
that's that's also the dangerous part is
like he is not only watching the
princess is that every house was there
at that party and they're like yes that
one guard not the lead guard not the
king of the guards that guard that
watches the princess killed a man at the
wedding yeah
every single house side that makes you
look more there this episode made their
house look so weak just because viserys
is dying in front of everyone
hide those coughs but like also seeing
that you're like this house is a mess
I'm kind of glad I didn't get married
seeing the queen come out in green
against her fam like family she's
married into late showing up on purpose
that guy accusing Damon of killing his
wife the middle of a party that family
the targaryens are a mess the house
because they're like I gotta go to a
Targaryen party I'd be like yeah last
time I went uh I already killed a man I
didn't see I didn't like zoom in yet
we'll have to wait for Eric's breakdown
which will be on the channel tomorrow uh
did we see any Starks or baratheons in
the background they must have been there
right I'm sure they were the Baratheon
I'm sure somewhere I mean you had the
they made a point to show us like the
high towers and the Lannisters of course
who was the one that was like I'm on
side with your family that was talking
to Allison oh that's her that's her
uncle oh like who is Otto's older
brother he he's he's the lord of the at
the scene of Old Town never mind I was
like there was another but they were
basically like okay we'll back you
whatever power play you want to make
we're on your side you got you you know
your son in our eyes he's the heir like
we'll make that happen
um well that leads us to like one of our
next questions right how is Allison
going to use her knowledge of Sir
Kristen and Rainier okay because
knowledge of the truth is a powerful
thing in this world and right now
Allison has now been made aware that
Kristen Cohen right now had a little
thing okay she lost her maiden Hood to
just aggressed and cold yeah
um and now she knows this and she goes
to kind of save Kristen Cole at the end
there and as you pointed out he's going
to be on her side he's going to be on
her side well first off Allison is now
becoming is in her villain origin story
she is doing her Village in Orange and
story so it makes sense that she would
be like no I'm not gonna kill you but
I'm gonna use what I have like over your
head and you're gonna be on my team but
also I'm not gonna like do it in an
abusive manner she's just gonna be like
you're mad at her and we're mad at them
and I don't want her to succeed and you
don't want her to succeed like just work
with me work with me do you think he's
gonna like use or she's gonna use him as
like a spy like hey keep up what you've
been doing and keep up the good work my
God the thing is like because there's I
think there's still a difference between
being upset and mad and angry and love
and that's the thing is like even if
she's like I need you to spy on uh
renera for me I don't think he'd
actually do it but he'd give other
secrets I'm sure of he'd be like let me
tell you about laner Elena Elena let me
tell you let me tell you about Elena
he's gonna probably out a lot of [ __ ]
about that Valerian I mean if I'm
Rainier I'm like okay this has gone far
enough this is why you don't hook up
with the people you work with you know
what I mean I gotta get this guy out of
my department let's get him guarding the
other side I don't think she loves him I
think she does but after seeing this
she's like I can't deal with this she
has the you know the song of ice and
fire on her back it's her job to get out
there to you know even though she's
afraid of childbirth I think she
realizes the prince that was promised is
a thing right and if it's not me it's
the next one and I have to keep the
lineage going I have to keep the
Targaryen line in power yeah and if I'm
going to be the heir I'm going to have
to have a kid at some point yeah and I'm
sure in her mind it's like well let me
find suitors uh Damon for some reason is
on that list uh it's a Targaryen thing
it keeps the blood blah blah blah and
she's into him she's been groomed by him
uh so Kristen Cole was on that list
because he's like he's a strong guy he's
a good fighter he's loyal he's Noble as
far as she knows so it's like I'll put
him on the list uh and now he's turned
out to be a problem I don't know if
she's like I can get it do I use him
just as a stud to try and get an air
here or do I look somewhere else the
thing is maybe I like that over over at
good old break bones you know I'm
talking about he came in he rescued her
from The Fray he threw up on her on her
shoulder just what she was asking for
someone come take me away uh he's gonna
be he's on the kingsguard like he's a
very strong dude he would be a good
candidate do you think they're gonna
they have have this day kind of online
with the book which we won't talk about
I'm not going to talk about what we're
going to talk about yeah but
um I just think that
she can't have a baby with a Christian
Cole because it's like people got a
baby's gonna look yeah baby don't look
like well I think at this point she
realizes if I have a kid with this guy
he's not gonna be chill about it and be
like oh it's not my kid don't worry he's
gonna freak out at some point and be
let's let's get on the boat 100
steal this baby and we're gonna get on
the oh the orange boat sail around and
me and my baby are gonna we're gonna
sell oranges also yes I don't know Lake
Nora is [ __ ] pissed yes yes he's so
pissed that's the man that killed his
lover yeah and that was part of the deal
is I get to bring my goose with it's
yeah and oh my God Top Gun
like Top Gun uh very gay but it also is
just like during that time do you know
how hard it is probably to find someone
that you love that is of the same sex uh
and love not just go to that brothel in
the basement and hook up with it's like
love he loved Joffrey and Joffrey is now
dead and it's like my my person that
you've made a deal with is dead buy
yours yeah what are you sacrificing yeah
no I'm gonna sacrifice your guys's son
sir Kristen Cole and you're a son
uh yeah I think it's going to be very
interesting to see how he plays but yeah
he's definitely on team Allison now for
sure yeah for sure me too
um well let's talk a little bit about
this song of ice and fire like because
this is a big thing that is new for this
show that wasn't in the books the idea
that there was this uh story passed down
by the from the targaryens about the
threat of like you know the winter
that's coming uh is this something that
Rainier is gonna share with Lena yeah
you think she'll tell him about it I
think she'll tell them about it also
because after seeing Leonard ride that
Dragon I was like oh you can just
involve him in a lot of things I guess
it's more so if she trusts him but I
feel like she's after she loses the
series she doesn't have anyone to trust
so it's like just work with your cousin
yeah he's still your cousin let him know
why you are why you're important yeah
why you need to stay here just so his
parents will stop trying to make him the
king of like everything of the Seven
Kingdoms um I think it would be easier I
I would hope she'd just do it I'd hope
she'd just do it it would be smart to
tell this guy to be like hey I need you
to just be cool yeah this is very
important this is yes it's about ruling
Westeros and our families having power
blah blah blah but there's a bigger
thing in here to play it here I need to
have an heir it could be you I mean if
he you know they could find a way to to
do I'm sure the maesters could think of
something
let's try some herbal stuff or something
the other maze is like
through all that money we're doing real
science here with leeches and the guy
still gives it to strong like here at
least give him some some of my drugs
maybe some herbal herbal medicine I
forgot I was like I forgot how
ridiculous the maesters were the maester
was in Game of Thrones and I was like
damn they have a track record of just
not being good my wife was like what's
wrong with his arm I'm like that's the
stuff they're putting out to heal it it
doesn't look good uh yeah he's a mess oh
yeah I love doing it when Raines like
kind of shook his hand you could feel
that like that oh you guys weren't there
it was like oh I kind of thought she was
like I think she did it on purpose as
like a hand check like how's this boy
doing that's okay
yeah it would be interesting because it
does seem like this is a secret I assume
like viserys told his wife Emma his
first wife Emma about it yeah probably
when he was like kind of being like
really need that air honey really need
to get it going here you don't want to
do it uh but I don't think he's told
Allison about it no but Allison is
Allison he's only with Allison because
the kingdom was like Hey get another one
like he and he knows that so he's like a
lot about the past and about yeah Mother
Goose watches him uh build his little
his little Lego set yeah I get that but
I'm also like he I don't think he sees
her like I just told her that no it's
and also now especially he's like I got
rid of her dad yeah and viserys looks
dumb most of the time but I think he's
can do smart things and I think he knows
that like my wife is upset that I killed
off her dad not Guild off but like got
rid of him got rid of him well and she's
I mean and Allison's bad because yeah
her dad was dismissed for telling the
truth uh and then okay for telling the
truth for spying on Race she didn't have
sex with him but yeah and then viserys
is like no no no you know we can't have
it blah blah blah and it cost her that
and now to come to find out that she's
been lied to by Ramirez it's like my dad
got dismissed for doing the right thing
uh and now and now I don't have my
friend I don't have my husband on my
side necessarily I don't know who you
trusts it's so hard because yeah you
don't know how to trust and also I I
like me my first instinct is like
Allison don't be stupid but we need to
remember that Allison was a little girl
that was raised with just like her dad
after her mom died and her brother I
don't know what he's doing again and the
dad literally was like go go to the King
go to the king so if you're raised in
that time if you're raising that time
and the only person in the parental
figure you have is your dad you're gonna
be on his side even if he and his kind
of slotted you out and his goodbye
really freaked her out it was like Hey
I'm not joking like you're gonna die he
was like something and then what did he
call he said something oh my God he said
something to her he kind of throws shade
at his own daughter a lot because he's
like you're the prettiest girl but the
dumbest girl right now like he'll say
things like that and I'm like damn but
he said something to her at the
beginning of this conversation where I
was like okay I guess Allison still love
him yeah uh and finally real quick as on
the house of the Dragon uh what do you
think the future could hold for Damon
and Elena Valerian I mean clearly it
looks like the show is setting uh us up
to for them to get together I could see
and that's the thing I could see Corliss
giving Damon her I mean why not why not
have two targaryens like either way it
seems like you're gonna get someone in
control yeah and also yeah he was the
one that killed the crab the crab the
crab feeder yeah he still has like the
crabfitters mask a little trophy exactly
like so look at it like look what we did
we beat the crab feeder yeah so I could
easily see Damon and she's older now so
I could see Corliss easily just being
like yeah you can have my daughter if
you want her I mean surely she's heard
stories about this guy no did because
every all the young girls are like oh
that's Damon he's a bad boy and he's a
bad he always hooks up with women but
they don't know that he doesn't finish
he doesn't go all the way don't point it
out oh yeah don't put it out if it
happens just just don't mention it oh
that was good now I'm going to sleep oh
nice try honey nice try uh okay well
that's some good houses of the Dragon
talk but we can't go any further on
talking Dragons without visiting our
other little fantasy show it's time to
do a little talking Toki little talking
talking beautiful uh so this was episode
four The Great Wave uh was the name of
the episode and so also where we start
off the episode with we see the queen
regent Muriel having a vision of numenor
being destroyed by A Great Wave we'd
later see this comes from the plantier
uh but in this episode episode Galadriel
manages to piss off Muriel once again
and she gets locked up next to Howell
brand she wants the people of numenora
to help fight Sauron which nobody sees
as a problem everyone's like sauron's is
gone what are you talking about lady
especially the men of numenor they hate
the elves they're sick of them they
don't want to talk about these elves
anymore get them out of here we also see
foreign who's on like the council there
he comes to take Galadriel back to the
elves he's like we're going to sail you
back to Middle Earth you're going back
to your people uh but she escapes and
kind of like lets her Escape it's kind
of messy uh but she escapes uh and she
goes to newborn finds out that the king
is old and dying in his Tower that's
kind of been the secret area we could
have guessed didn't they like the guards
came to take her away and she like beat
them all up yes it kind of gets away and
then like phrase on kind of like lets
her go because Hall Brand's like just
let I know where she's going Show's very
beautiful Show's very pretty but that
choreography fight scene was a little
sluggish because I I noticed it and I
was like I didn't see enough
hand-to-hand combat right now how did
this work out there was a better fight
scene in the show yes there was that's
why I'm like I see it
and she gets away so uh she meets with
Miro on the tower where the old man is
uh and she sees the truth about what's
going on so the Muriel takes uh
Galadriel to the planeteer where these
are like these special stones or if you
touch them they kind of you can see
things across space and time and this
one shows you like numenor's end uh and
Muriel points out like this this whole
thing begins with you coming here and
now you're here so I need you to get out
basically I'm glad you're always like no
I gotta do the same we gotta fight
Sauron uh and this is great line for
Muriel where she says faith May bind one
heart but is to find a thread from which
to hang a kingdom which is powerful
stuff because like Muriel's looking out
for her own kingdom here you know her
dad wanted to go back uh be friends with
the elves and it caused like a big
rebellion and so she's like I'm just
trying to like keep the peace here
um so they're gonna send Galadriel away
gonna send her back to Middle Earth but
just as they do uh the petals from the
white tree but yeah just like the tears
of Valar uh this is a bad Omen so Muriel
says screw that plan we're going to help
Galadriel I'm sending an army over there
everyone's signing up it's going to be
so much fun uh and our boy Hal brand is
free and out of jail we see that too uh
more about that guy in a second uh back
back at the orc camp we meet Adar what a
good looking fella uh the Orcs call him
father and he really seems to care about
them he's pretty sad when he meets That
Dying orc and he's like I'll just finish
you off but boom Dead uh it turns out
that Adar is like a dark elf he speaks
like the elfish language and he meets
with Iran deer and kind of is like hey
Soldier how's it hanging where are you
from uh uh also you've been lied to your
whole life he says this interesting
thing about these lies that take root in
the rocks and the roots
in this episode swearing on the mountain
and stuff like all that all that very
important stuff uh and he basically lets
a Ron deer go and is like I got a
message for you go tell it to the people
of the Southland and we also find out
that the Orcs all this digging that
they're doing doing they're looking for
the sword Hill that Theo had found
earlier and we see again this episode uh
meanwhile Bronwyn and all the other
villagers from across the Southland are
hiding out from the Orcs And The Elves
former Watchtower osterife osterife this
was a place that was made up for the
show there's a new place not in the
books but uh that we saw in an earlier
episode The Elves got out of there quick
because there was like no one there when
they got there uh but so they're all
hiding out there but the rations are
running low so Theo and his like friend
who is not a good friend decide to go
out I would have done the same thing
I'll be like peace I'm out of here well
the thing is I would have said peace I'm
out of here left the food that kid
empty-handed
nope uh so Theo gets in a little bit of
a mess but a reindeer saves him uh in a
very cool sequence where he's catching
arrows yeah right before he hits him in
the chassis you better use that some
good stuff some good stuff uh and he he
gets Theo back uh to austereth and he
tells Bronwyn the message from Adar
which is basically surrender or die not
much of a choice there uh tough stuff
tough stuff uh as we mentioned Thea is
still counting around that sword hilt he
pierced his own skin to give it a little
blood and we see that like you give it
enough blood it grows to like full
length I don't know how long it lasts
for because I was like it goes back down
it needs a fresh supply of blood to keep
it and it has to be like human blood
because when he was slicing through the
was did he say he sliced the finger off
of one of the Orcs yeah when fighting
and nothing happened and I was like oh
yeah once like that I was like oh it's
interesting I was like why why isn't it
using his blood it's always in your
blood we turned out he stole it from
that guy waldrig I believe name is who
confronts him in the campus like I know
you stole it boy you like that thinking
he's pretty cool huh he's like that
weird uncle that you have that might
have like he like grabbed them yeah yeah
I was like let go it's like when you go
to a flea market and there's that guy
selling like Nazi memorabilia you're
like why do you have all this stuff
but he's like
Hickory is like yeah someone's coming
have you heard of this guy Sauron and
he's like uh that that meteor that
shooting star that's like a sign that
he's coming back that's a sign that he's
coming but so that old man is not Sauron
I the old man waldrick who confronted
not the element no the one the flock
yeah well we'll talk about that in a
second uh so but that also shows us that
like everyone in Middle Earth saw this
thing that's an important thing yes uh
meanwhile elrond discovers what Prince
Duran has been hiding in his Mountain uh
he found a new or harder than iron and
lighter than silk it's mythrail mithril
if you're familiar with the series
you've heard of this before that's like
that chain mail thing uh that Bilbo
wears at one point I believe one of the
Rings is made of mithril yes one of the
Rings of power uh the dwarves call it
gray glitter which I kind of like it's
called Greg Greg I like how everyone's
like oh no mithril and we know the word
mithril but they're like well
he's like you would call it mithril
we're gonna call Gregory later and
everyone's going to call them everybody
sorry I'm sorry it doesn't work out that
way uh so yeah another fun episode a lot
of fantasy in this one I love that fake
fight sequence this is a big question on
this show right yes who is Sauron it's
Theo you think it's Steve and I hope
it's there oh I hope it's Theo I wanted
to be so bad I run there is totally
Theo's dad right
oh I take it to be to these Theo's Dad
no and I know Bronwyn and irondir are
kind of like weird it seemed like they
haven't hooked up yet but I think they
have hooked up in the past interesting
Rhonda keeps trying to bring it up but
she's like I want to talk about it I
don't want to talk about it oh I think
irondiro's Theo's dad I could see that
I'm seriously oh interesting and it
leans more human than it does elf yeah
because I think it well there's people
that are like half elf half human and at
some point you make a decision oh yeah
because that's what that's what happened
to numenor uh so it's like I think I
don't know I don't know that's just my
thing but using Theo could be I wanted
to be Theo so bad I think it'd be fun if
it is Theo especially has the hilt right
now and it just keeps he's gonna get so
obsessed with that power he's gonna go
crazy he's gonna go crazy for that power
I mean I'm I've not read a lot of Lord
of the Rings and when I say a lot I mean
zero I've seen the movies that's about
it uh so I'm very interested in this
like who is it gonna be yeah I think I I
assumed it was just going to be Adar
himself like that dark elf I just assume
he would become Sauron but it seems more
like now he's trying to facilitate
someone coming around I mean the guy
falling from the sky would be
interesting I thought especially if like
the hard foots have helped Sauron along
his way uh I mean I I was also kind of
talking with producer dashlaw about this
like uh it could be sauroman himself too
because like we don't know where
sauroman is right now necessarily it
could be him I think another candidate
for Sauron is Hal brand
who's hiding out on you he's a really
interesting guy do you think oh because
that weird like freak out where he
actually was a great fighter yeah he's
like a great fighter he's like I thought
he was an heir well that's the thing
Galadriel is so set that he's like the
missing King of the Southlands or
something like she's just saying it out
right now not even being like I think
he's this she's like he is this which
makes you think he's totally not that uh
and he's gonna turn out to be Sauron and
he's just kind of like in hiding because
like his plan before didn't go well so
he's like hiding out and he just wants
to be on numenora and like chill so what
if the story that she's seen with new
menorah's downfall is like it starts
with you but it's because you're
bringing this this you brought sour on
yeah oh my God I would love that well
and we know that like Galadriel and
Sauron have like a shared history at
some point over she lives a very long
life obviously in this fight a lot of
battles so I I don't know it would just
be very interesting for my narrative
perspective too if like how brand is
kind of working with uh
uh galadriana way to gain this power
because like you know these forges need
to get built so that the rings of power
can get made so that the one ring can
give me it's like a long con by Sauron
yes uh so it'd be interesting if like if
that that's what it turns out I would
love that I'm here for that I'm here for
both of us but I like yours yeah I like
the Theo idea that's very interesting we
wouldn't see it coming uh I have a quick
which is better for you we had two looks
at two different crowns from our two
shows uh we've got that the the crowns
that the elves wear that durian was
wearing King Durham was wearing it was
like a very heavy metal crown with
spikes oh there you there you go oh yes
yes
I love it it looks like a trash do you
like background better than the Crown we
have on House of the Dragon he's the one
that viserys wears easily like better I
like the one
that's funny because every time we have
to do the either or I always lean rings
of power and I have like kind of like
very fantastic yeah yeah also the
dwarves straight up made theirs they're
chiseled there
yeah so I was like oh this is cool I
like this way more and it's spiky so you
can stab someone with it
okay I like that I think I like that one
too it's very cool I like that I like
the the crown from Westeros it's very
cool it's very cool but like yeah I like
that dwarf Crown the door right it's so
heavy uh who would you rather have your
back in a fight would you rather have
break bones himself uh I have sir sir
Harwin strong or would you rather have
Hal brand on your side how Brandon has
shown himself pretty good you already
know who I'm going for that's why you're
doing that's why you're that's why
you're trying to defend home run uh yeah
brick boats easily he picks me up and
Carries me through the crowd like a
linebacker he actually gets through
people if break boats is going against
the guys that Hall brand was going
against it would have been over over
with okay okay I like Albright I mean
hot brand had some good moves he's also
very crafty with the time I think he's a
silver team I was like yeah he's just
good at me he's very sneaky he's very
stink I might check out brown with me uh
there were two great soundtrack moments
on the show I mean both soundtracks on
these shows are so good uh but I want to
ask two moments from you uh which
soundtrack moment did you like better
when uh Iran deer is fighting in the
woods 100 and they break through the
trees and the Sun comes out of the Orcs
100
or or or
when the valerians show up at King's
Landing yeah and those drums are kicking
in yeah
and they come in I mean the music
throughout the whole wedding was great I
loved it but I when you said the
soundtrack I was like what soundtrack
for rings of power and I was like oh
unless it's and then you said when I
came to the woods and I was like yeah
uh uh the uh during his wife singing uh
yeah yes yes yes yes yes what's the song
called though I forget what the name she
was singing or the song she was saying
but uh she's singing it into the
mountains to release the the dwarves who
are trapped and they do get out they all
survive but that was like a really
beautiful those two songs are so so good
that transition was so good oh that's
what first off just him catching the
arrow was enough to be like that was
pretty like I was like this was the
coolest thing I've ever seen on TV we've
seen that happen in the movies I love
the elves that's a good outfit I love it
and then he runs out of bows but they
make it right in time in that sun and
the Orcs way and the little fat work was
my favorite and he was like and I was
like this is great
uh you guys are all very lucky to still
have your heads uh God damn I love that
scene so yeah I choose that I choose
rings of power okay so far
music I mean that way there's drums for
the Valerian it was great so good I'm
two rings of power one one half of the
Dragon so good okay well let's wrap up
this episode let's talk Power Rankings
all right let's talk about Power
Rankings we'll start with House of the
Dragon who's up this week on House of
the Dragon who gained the most power on
House of the Dragon this week
foreign
still gonna have to lean
still gonna have to lean Allison oh so
that's a pretty good I think like it's
really like she lost her dad but she got
sir Kristen Cole she got her uncle's
side and they're gonna now split people
are gonna start taking sides right and
she's finally stepping into her role as
a queen yeah like she's like oh
well [ __ ]
I mean I feel like she's officially
fully lost raymura yeah and her mind
done cut time and I think in her mind
she's done with the Sarah's too yeah
because he was kind of hiding stuff from
her she should just kill him
but keep going I don't know
and then people will be like he just
died from the leeches yeah
I mean I would say that Lenor Valerian
got a lot of power this week you know
marrying marrying the air bringing a lot
of power to the family combining some
Dragon riding families together that's
what I would say too but then I was like
after he lost his partner watch him pull
us or Chris and Cole I think it's gonna
be pretty actress he's gonna be pretty
depressed it's gonna be tough for him
but he needs to look and see these
gandal out of power he does he has
gained a lot of power does I mean
Damon's gained a house but uh Damon
would be my second Damon would be my
second Damon just gained a lot and he
still doesn't care so he was like I'm
gonna be mean to everybody uh who do you
think gained the most power on rings of
power this week what do you think who do
you think getting the most
definitely not numenor not the city of
numerals they're not gaining no power I
honestly the Orcs I think uh the leader
of the darker yeah 100 he is barreling
through them and he's like tell them
send this message that's how weak
everyone is right now he's like send the
message for me yeah and we didn't get
enough of the hard foots right the heart
the harfords we didn't see the hardwoods
we didn't see them at all this was an
alpha numenor story yeah yeah and uh
yeah Adar knows where the hilt is now
the Orcs have told him like it's in the
tower so oh yeah
get the boy
um and so I think it's definitely him
hey dog getting the most power okay I
would say I think this week
I think how Brands gained a lot of power
because I think he's made a little deal
with foreign who clearly wants to take
over get Queen Muriel out of there
they're about to sail away uh they're
about to leave with a bunch of fighting
men and I think what's going to be left
in the city are the men that don't like
the elves so they're certainly not going
to help take her back to Middle Earth
yeah uh and like people like ferezon
who's going to help halbrand get power
in the city that he wants to be in true
I think Hal brand gained a lot of power
this week okay I think he just got out
of prison but that's that's just I mean
he did he did it's tough to get a job
with the guild when you're fresh out of
prison Who's down this week who lost
something sir Kristen
this is
I mean I think a couple weeks ago I said
he had gained the most power by getting
on the Kings yard Boy Lost It All fifth
episode downhill he is in the negatives
he he's got to do what he did with that
unprovoked he admits it he he gets in a
fight in front of everybody kills the
man in front of everybody and then three
he can't even my guy can't even kill
himself in people can't kill himself
also I would even add he laid his whole
heart out
that's great I mean I love an orange
every now and then but uh
geez I got this whole kingdom here and I
got dragons where's the dragon gonna go
on the boat yeah where's my dragon gonna
go you know I love my dragon even bring
up and then people are going to notice
who I am in this guy I gotta dye my hair
my hair what are you talking about yeah
he's down he's he's down pretty bad
horribly he's down pretty bad uh I think
I'd have to say him too I mean it's
pretty bad I'd put it for Sarah it's up
there I mean yeah physically everyone I
think everyone like viserys's generation
like viserys even Corliss and Ramis I
think it's like they lost they think
they're gaining a lot of power by
marrying the targaryens but I think
their generation is out it's not about
them anymore and they're they're going
to find like no one gives a [ __ ] what
they think anymore so I think it's it's
a lot of power loss for viserys yeah his
wife one of them his his brother yet
again made him look like a chump Yeah by
showing up to the place he was banished
from like he can't do it and he's
bleeding all over the place
leech to death Jesus
still further than he is and this man is
physically dying physically dying uh who
lost the most power on rings of power
this week uh the the queen of numenor
the Kingston yeah I honestly think it's
her and I think she lost them the thing
is she gave her a surrounding speech I
love the speech even the other guy's
speech great speeches all you have to do
is say a speech and they're on your side
yeah honestly I would have just talked
about how to bake a cake and people
would have been on my side but I think
she just going off and saying like she's
aware that her entire City's doomed
period so they're already under they're
already going down so that she's just
what is she trying to do make it go
higher by not disclosing any information
just I just want to take care of my dad
until the final days yeah and I'm like
and now you're going with her to the
Middle East
everything's going to be demolished and
if Sauron is that's a bad idea you the
Visions are coming true and you left
yeah that's a horrible that's a stupid
idea it's not a good look it's not a
good look uh I think
yeah I think Mario lost a lot of power
this week and really I think
in a way Galadriel kind of lost a lot of
power I mean I should go to the Army now
she's got a little team up but I think
on the same vein like they're missing
the bigger picture yeah and I think that
all brand is the one kind of tricking
them into this whole thing uh so yeah
not not looking good she always is a
college
I pronounce it I pronounce it horribly
but she is always down in my book she
constantly is just like I can't wait
until she comes to the conclusion that
maybe fighting everyone isn't the right
idea yeah she's too focused she's too
it's too black or white with her right
it is there's no and someone said that
to her yeah he's like when he points out
he's like what do you do if you know
your enemy's weakness she's like you
exploit it you just have to explain him
she's like no you you find a solution
for it and you'll be the one that kind
of provides it because then you hold all
the power yeah she's basically tricking
her constantly she's messy right now
yeah you found this guy in the ocean
keep your eyes open he's like I can
trust him like you stupid stupid
well that's it for this episode of big
question presents talking dragons uh be
sure to join us back here next week and
each and every week on new rockstars
we're gonna be Spitting Fire with the
targaryens talking rings of power uh
it's a fun time we're so glad you guys
are here to join us don't forget to
check out our mini great merch options
over at new rockstarsmerch.com uh you
can follow the lovely Jessica Clemens
here at Lulu underscore Clements follow
me at grin and Barrick and make sure to
subscribe to new rockstars uh and this
podcast wherever you you consume it
however you consume it just subscribe we
thank you so much for watching and we'll
see you here next week bye-bye
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign